Bonjour à toutes et à tous
A tous et à toutes, Bonjour
Si nous sommes avec vous ce matin c’est
pour vous parler du système immunitaire.
Un sujet dense et passionnant.
Un sujet passionnant et dense.
Et pour commencer
Pour démarrer les festivités,
Nous allons vous chanter
Nous allons plutôt slamer mon cher Mathis
Oui, vous avez raison Juliette nous allons
plutôt slamer
Musique !
Tout a commencé par une reconnaissance
Puis une activation
Et une multiplication
Je suis une cellule du système immunitaire
Mais Wesh, qu’est-ce tu vas faire ??
Baiser de la mort
Un simple contact
Et paf t’es mort !
Moi j’tue les bactéries, les virus et j’te
défends
Pour finir je suis le Lymphocyte T
Lymphocyte T
On m’appelle TUEUR !!!
Bonjour !
Vous savez ce qu’est une maladie ?
Autrefois, on parlait d’infection.
Il était même admis que les maladies venaient
de « germes malfaisants »
J’ai dit Germe ! Retenez bien ce mot,
un germe est quelque chose de tout petit.
De plus petit encore que les tiques qui s’accrochent
aux poils des chiens ou à leur chair.
Oui, un germe est tout petit,
si petit qu’on ne peut le voir à l’œil nu.
Et pour voir ce
germes, nous avons des appareils appelés microscopes !
MICROSCOPE, vous comprenez ? Microscope et même Ultra microscope !
Grâce à ces instruments que nous approchons de nos yeux, les germes nous apparaissent
plus grands qu’ils ne sont en réalité.
Et nous percevons ainsi toutes ces choses
minuscules dont nous ignorons l’existence!
Les meilleurs de ces ultramicroscopes peuvent grossir les germes 1 million de fois !
C’est ENORME !
Non, c’est MINUSCULE.
Il est mignon n’est-ce pas ? Ratus
Ratus ou rat noir, c’est un rongeur commun
à longue queue, de la sous-famille des Murinaé.
Il paraît inoffensif et pourtant il est porteur
de la bactérie Yersinia Pestis, agent de la Peste.
Au moyen-âge, c’est ce rat qui est responsable
du fléau, d’ailleurs près de la moitié
de la population européenne a été décimé
en seulement quelques années, à cause de ce rat
Mais comment ce rat transmet-il cette bactérie
à l’homme ? Shona ????? »
Ce sont les puces qui, en aspirant le sang de rats porteurs de peste, absorbent
les microbes
qu’elles peuvent ensuite transmettre à l’homme à cause d'une piqure.
Comme les rats vivent près des hommes il
n’y a qu’un saut de puce entre le rat et l'homme.
Heureusement cette maladie a totalement
disparu.
Bah non, tu te trompes,
il existe encore quelques cas isolés
Comme par exemple : En Amérique du sud,  Afrique, et même en Asie.
Et en Bretagne ?
Non je te rassure pas en Bretagne,
Puis de toute façon cette maladie se guérie grâce à des antibiotiques
bonjour, bienvenue, comment-ça va , en langues différentes.
ça va Jean ?
Aaatchoum, je ne te salue pas j’ai
attrapé la grippe en Espagne
Ah oui,ni la fameuse propagation intercontinentale
des virus
ça doit être ça. Comme tu dis…
Il y a longtemps les
gens vivaient et habitaient au même endroit
Mais quand l’Empire Romain a commencé
à conquérir le monde tout a changé.
Et puis il y a eu le commerce avec
des nomades d’Asie et d’ailleurs
et ces commerçants rapportaient avec eux des
maladies inconnues.
Sans oublier les grandes explorations
qui ont décimé les indiens avec la propagation de la variole et de la rougeole
Et aujourd’hui, avec le réchauffement
climatique tout s’accélère : le chikungunya, la malaria
Et ta grippe espagnole
Et bien sûr grâce aux vaccins
je suis sauvé, merci Louis Pasteur !
D’ailleurs, cher Public, nous vous
laissons en sa compagnie
Martine a la rage, Scène 1 : Le marché
Vendeuse de poisson : « Pas cher, pas cher
il est frais mon poisson ! Bonjour Madame Pasteur que prendriez-vous cette semaine ? »
Marie Pasteur : « Du thon comme d’habitude
»
Aaaaaaarghhhh
ça ne vas pas Madame, que vous arrive-t-il
?
Vous n’allez pas mourir sur mon
étale !
J’ai été mordu par un chien il
y a un mois
Venez voir mon mari il pourra vous
soigner
Non par pitié pas le médecin
Mais je vous assure que c'est mieux pour vous, vous devriez m’écouter
Scène 2 : Au laboratoire de Pasteur
Louis ? Où est-ce que tu es passé ?
Ah Louis, je t’amène une patiente,
elle a de la fièvre et sa joue est infectée
Pas de boutons, pas de vomissements,
ce sont les symptômes de la rage.
Je ne suis pas encore tout à fait au point
avec le vaccin mais il faut tenter notre chance.
Moi me vacciner, jamais, je ne suis
pas une vache ni un cochon hors de question
Moi aussi je suis contre,
une bonne infusion de thym et de miel fera l’affaire , je suis le docteur KKuéte,
grand docteur très expérimenté.
J’ai entendu vos âneries
au marché et il est hors de question que vous empoisonniez cette femme
Vous n’êtes qu’un charlatan,
voici plusieurs années que j’étudie la
maladie dans mon laboratoire, j’ai trouvé
le sérum, regardez, voici le germe de la rage
j’injecte le vaccin, vous pouvez voir
au microscope qu’il détruit totalement la maladie
convaincu ?
Sottise ! Et pourquoi pas me faire
croire que la terre ronde et que l’eau mouille ?
Messieurs, s’il vous plaît, Miss
Martine ne va pas bien
Oh nan elle est morte
Je le savais, nous aurions dû la
vacciner
Je vous l’avais bien dit !
Alala qu'est-ce qu'ils sont bêtes ceux-là
Tiens salut Thomas! Salut Steven ! Dis moi, tu connais le virus de l'hépatite C?
Oui , bien sûr! Il est, par ailleurs, souvent comparé au Cheval de Troie.
Ah bon ? et peux-tu me dire pourquoi?
Parce que c'est un virus indétectable, et comme les Troyens dans leur Cheval, il se cache.
Ce virus utilise les liproprotéines pour rentrer dans ses cellules cibles, les cellules hépatite.
D'ailleurs, aucun scientifique n'a réussi à découvrir ce virus si petit.
Et tu sais quel organe touche ce virus?
BAH oui , bien sûr , c'est le foie!
Maligne cette maladie de l‘hépatite
C
Bah oui, c’est comme si on enfermait les soldats dans le cheval
Exactement
Moi dès que j’ai des symptômes
de maladie je me blinde de médicaments
doliprane, vitamine
C
Attention cependant, il ne faut
pas faire n’importe quoi avec les médicaments
s la surdose peut entrainer des effets secondaires redoutables
la surdose
peut même amener l’overdose
connais-tu l’histoire du Docteur Jeckyll et Mr Hyde?
Non, je ne la connais pas…
Alors regarde
Le Dr Jeckyll était un homme droit, très respecté
par toute la haute société londonienne du XIXème siècle.
Un jour, dévoré par l’ennui, il créa
une potion lui permettant de devenir quelqu’un d'autre
un être violent, passionnel et
compulsif nommé Mr Hyde !
Rapidement le Docteur Jekyll ne pouvait plus se passer de Hyde,
il viva alors une double vie
entre raison et pulsion, entre humanité et animalité
entre les valeurs morales et les actes morbide.
A chaque nouvelle transformation en Hyde il
devait augmenter la dose d’injection
et le retour au réel était toujours plus difficile que la veille.
Il devint de plus en plus difficile de se
détacher de ce Mr Hyde.
Peu a peu, Jekyll n’était plus que l’ombre
de lui même.
Enfermé chez lui, épuisé et dévoré par
la culpabilité il finit par se suicider
en laissant derrière lui une lettre expliquant
son terrible secret.
C’est vraiment glaçant cette histoire.
C’est pour cela qu’il faut consulter
si tu ne vas pas bien et ne pas faire tes propres potions
Nous vous remercions cher public de votre écoute.
Nous espérons que notre présentation vous
aura éclairé sur le système immunitaire,
un système qui nous protège des agressions
extérieures mais que nous devons également protéger
Et maintenant, En guise d’épilogue, nous vous invitons
à écouter Youna et Manon qui ont une petite histoire à vous raconter
Knebworth – 9 août 1986 – Nos parents
se rencontrent lors d’un concert de Queen.
On ne le sait pas encore mais cette date si
importante pour mes parents c’est aussi celle du dernier concert de Freddy Mercury.
Diagnostiqué en 1987 atteint du VIH il décédera
le 24 novembre 1991 à Londres.
Rennes – 3 juin 2019 – Le liberté, concert
hommage à Freddy Mercury .
Ce soir , ma sœur et moi nous avons rdv avec 2 garcons du lycée.
et on vas au concert ensemble.
Et si quelque chose se passe, ne vous inquiétez pas nous nous protégerons.
En France chaque année  6000 personnes découvrent
leur séropositivité au Sida
et trop de jeunes de notre âge pensent que cette maladie
peut se guérir avec une simple pilule
ou s’attraper avec un simple baiser.
Tu es prête ? on y va ?